House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, war with Dorne and go all the
way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
This summer, it was reported and recently
confirmed by Entertainment Weekly that HBO
has released a casting call for Princess Rhaenyra
Targaryen, a key figure from this time period
of the Dance of the Dragons.
The casting call describes her: “King Viserys’
chosen heir,
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to become
the first ruling Queen of Westeros.”
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
One of the main characters in this series
is going to be Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight when she was young
and later called the Half-Year Queen, was
the first-born child of King Viserys I Targaryen.
Rhaenyra was King Viserys I's only living
child by his first wife,Queen Aemma of House
Arryn.
At the age of eight she was made her father's
hei
and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Rhaenyra was a dragonrider whose mount was
Syrax.
Rhaenyra had her family's Valyrian looks,
wearing her silver-gold hair in a long braid
in the manner of Queen Visenya Targaryen.
Beautiful as a child, Rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle, Prince Daemon Targaryen,
to be the most beautiful maiden in all the
Seven Kingdoms.
Due to the lack of a male heir, Viserys designated
Rhaenyra as his successor.
Therefore, Rhaenyra was the only female Targaryen
to lay claim to the Iron Throne in her own
right. Since she was raised as designated
heir, Rhaenyra became quite pampered and arrogant,
but also gained practical governmental experience.
After Rhaenyra's mother died, her father remarried
and had several sons with his second wife,
Alicent of House Hightower.
Even so, Viserys still publicly expected his
daughter to succeed him,
and when he died, his official will even stated
so.
However, Rhaenyra's younger half-brother,
Aegon, challenged her claim.
He stated that the normal inheritance laws
of the Andals (which formed the basis of the
unified law code in Westeros) called for male-preference
primogeniture, meaning that a younger son
would rightfully inherit before an older daughter.
Rhaenyra had 2 husbands and 5 sons. Her first
husband was Laenor of House Velayrion,
son of the Sea Snake. Laenor and Rhaenyra
had three sons together: Princes Jacaerys
'Jace',
Lucerys 'Luke', and Joffrey 'Joff' Velaryon.
All were near adulthood and had dragons of
their own when Rhaenyra's father, Viserys
I, died.
It was rumored that those sons of Rhaenyra's
were actually fathered by her champion and
lover,
Harwin Strong, the strongest man in Westeros,
called "Breakbones",
as all three were born with brown hair and
brown eyes, though Laenor and Rhaenyra both
had light silver/gold hair and purple eyes.
The Greens were the ones who sparked this
rumor, often calling them Strongs. The true
parentage of Rhaenyra's three eldest children
is still unclear.
The siblings Laenor and Laena Velaryon who
were married to Rhaenyra and Daemon Targaryen,
both died in 120 AC, as did Rhaenyra's alleged
lover, Breakbones. Rhaenyra then secretly
married her uncle, Prince Daemon, the most
experienced and the most dangerous warrior
of his time, at Dragonstone. The news of their
wedding caused a great scandal at the court
of King's Landing
and made Rhaenyra's father furious. It took
some time before Viserys and Daemon reconciled.
Rhaenyra's other sons, Princes Aegon and Viserys
Targaryen,
were fathered by Daemon and all had Targaryen
features.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone awaiting the birth of her
child.
The greens in King's Landing ensured that
the news of the Viserys's death did not reach
her until her own supporters in the Red Keep
were dead or imprisoned
and Aegon II's coronation had already occurred.
This began a devastating civil war that tore
apart the Seven Kingdoms, known as The Dance
of the Dragons, as it was the only war in
which both sides had dragonriders.
The war lasted for three years, and by the
time it came to an end nearly all of the Targaryen
dragons had been killed. The conflict also
resulted in the death of three of Rhaenyra's
five sons,
as well as the eldest son of Aegon II.
Rhaenyra's personal sigil was the normal Targaryen
heraldry (a three-headed red dragon on a black
field), quartered with the moon-and-falcon
sigil of House Arryn (for her mother Aemma
Arryn),
and the silver seahorse on sea green of House
Velaryon (for her first husband Laenor Velaryon,
as well as for the Velaryons in general, who
were among her major supporters).
During the Dance, her faction used her personal
heraldry as their battle-flag.
Aegon II held many advantages in the war,
including control of the capital city,
the support of the Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
and the approval of the High Septon.
Rhaenyra's faction was based at Dragonstone,
and to her advantage she had a larger number
of dragons under her control - twelve to Aegon's
four - though three of these were "wild" dragons
and as-yet untamed, while another three were
immature.
She also did not have enough Targaryen blood
relatives on her side to ride all of them,
and a dragon will (typically) the only bond
with someone possessing the blood of Old Valyria.
Thus a search was launched to find any surviving
Targaryen bastards - nicknamed the "dragonseeds"
- and enlist them in Rhaenyra's cause.
The two factions during the war - one supporting
Aegon and the other supporting Rhaenyra –
became known as the "Blacks" and the "Greens"
because of the incident that took place at
a tournament some years before the war began.
Aegon II's mother Queen Alicent had worn a
green dress to the tournament
while Rhaenyra wore a black dress.
The note was taken, and thereafter it became
the custom to refer to “greens” and “blacks”
when talking of the queen's party and the
party of the princess, respectively.
Generally, Rhaenyra was supported by noble
families who had enjoyed royal favor during
her father's reign and possessed strong ties
to the crown, while Aegon II rallied those
who had been out of favor. Viserys I had signed
charters with many powerful Houses
in which they swore to accept Rhaenyra as
his heir,
but at least some of them broke their word
after Viserys died.
Rhaenyra sent her eldest son Jacaerys north
on his dragon to visit the Eyrie and then
Winterfell.
At that time, the Vale was ruled by a female
heiress who had inherited in her own right
due to a lack of male heirs, and given that
the entire civil war questioned a woman's
right to rule,
she and Rhaenrya were natural allies.
Moreover, the Arryns had enjoyed royal favor
earlier in Viserys I's reign
since his first wife - Rhaenyra's own mother
- was an Arryn, thus binding the two families
by blood.
The Starks came into the war on Rhaenyra's
side in accordance with the original agreements
they had made with Viserys. Rhaenyra's second
son Lucerys flew on his dragon to Storm's
End to gain an alliance with House Baratheon,
but Aegon II's brother Aemond flew to Storm's
End
at the same time to pursue the same goal,
riding the older dragon Vhagar.
The results were decidedly mixed, and Storm's
End subsequently supported Aegon II.
Aemond, riding Vhagar, killed Luke over Shipbreaker
Bay
as he attempted to leave after failing to
gain Lord Borros' allegiance.
The Westerlands also sided with Aegon II because
he had appointed Tyland Lannister as his new
Master of Coin. The Hightowers were of course
staunch supporters of Aegon II,
and so apparently was much of the Reach. Dorne
had not been incorporated into the realm yet,
and as they have often done throughout history,
the Iron Islands remained neutral
while the mainlanders slaughtered each other
although they did the Blacks a favor when
they started attacking the Westerlands.
At some point during the war, Rhaenyra herself
was captured by Aegon II's forces
and was fed to her half-brother's dragon,
while her son was forced to watch.
Rhaenyra's three eldest sons all died fighting
during the Dance of the Dragons,
but her two youngest sons, the sons by her
second husband, Prince Daemon, survived the
civil war.
Rhaenyra's supporters led by House Tully and
House Stark continued to fight on
in the name of her two surviving sons,
however, and eventually triumphed: Through
uncertain circumstances, Aegon II died without
male heirs, and peace was achieved when Rhaenyra's
eldest surviving son was crowned as Aegon
III.
He was the son who had been forced to watch
his mother consumed by a dragon,
and he developed a deep hatred and fear of
the creatures.
So many dragons had died in the war that the
Targaryens couldn't maintain a stable breeding
population, and the few survivors became inbred
and sickly.
The last Targaryen dragons - the last dragons
in the known world - died during the reign
of Aegon III, earning him the sobriquet "Aegon
the Dragonbane".
Aegon III married Aegon II's surviving daughter
to re-unite the factions from the war,
though many cadet branches and relatives of
House Targaryen had been killed in the war.
Aegon III ruled well, and both of his sons
(Daeron I and Baelor I) became kings after
him,
but each died childless. Therefore, the throne
later passed to Rhaenyra's youngest son, Viserys
II,
who had served as Hand of the King under his
nephews for many years.
Viserys II was the father of Aegon IV and
grandfather of Daeron II,
and Daeron II was himself the grandfather
of Aerion Brightfame, Aegon V "the Unlikely",
and Maester Aemon. Neither Rhaenyra or Aegon
II are remembered well in the history of the
Westeros and many argue that neither side
truly won at the end,
but it's a fact that Rhaenyra's loyalists
won the war and Rhaenyra's children got the
throne.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters, especially Rhaenyra,
in the comment section down below. Thank you
so much for watching and hope to see you in
the next one. Peace!